[Music]
so Daniel you have actually asked a
question that I have never gotten before
and that is what is the most boring
thing in space can astronomers agree on
what the most boring thing is I normally
get asked about what the most
interesting things are in space but I've
never been asked about what the most
boring thing is and actually this gives
me a chance to talk about how science
works we have a saying in science that
everybody's data is somebody else's
noise and everybody's noise is somebody
else's data let me explain what that
means when you're taking a measurement
saying you want to observe a star that's
very far away there's stuff that can get
in the way there's a lot of gas and dust
in space between you and the star so
when you observe the light from the star
you need to correct out all that crud
that got in the way you don't want to
look at that you want to look at the
start but people who want to study the
gas and the dust itself can use the star
light as a probe to actually go through
it some people will be interested in
different parts of the data
everything you do in science there's a
bit that's inconvenient noisy you want
to actually correct it out from your
data somebody else wants to know about
that and some of the most amazing
discoveries in the universe have been
what people assumed were noises things
that had to be corrected things you
didn't want most spectacularly there's
something called the microwave
background radiation now there were some
astronomers back in the 1960s and 70s
that wanted to study the sky in
microwave light the Sun emits microwaves
the planets emit microwaves everywhere
they looked on the sky there was noise
there was a bit of background noise that
they wanted to correct out they did not
want that noise at all and they thought
it was a problem with their telescope at
first famously
there were pigeons roosting in the
telescope and they thought that the
pigeon poop might be generating this
noise so they scrubbed out all the
pigeon poop the no he's never went away
it stayed there every attempt they had
to make it go away and all of a sudden
people realize that what they had
detected what this noise was was a
signal from the Big Bang itself it was
actually the farthest observation of the
universe we've ever been able to make it
was from light shining from a distance
of 13.7 billion light years away the
Cosmic Microwave Background
so the answer is that there are plenty
of things in astronomy that I'm not
interested in plenty of things that get
in the way of my data that I want to
correct out and not know about and there
are other astronomers who want that
specific data
everybody's junk is somebody else's
treasure
[Music]